He currently,
I'm a professor of biology at Mit.
Gee.
Um,
I was actually more inclined towards,
uh,
chemistry,
maybe mathematics,
uh,
than biology.
In fact,
in high school I never studied biology
at all because I found it much too soft
as a science.
Uh,
then it was a characterization of a
taxonomy and species and phylon stuff
that I find it totally boring.
But in college,
uh,
at Mit when I was a freshman,
I was planning to major in,
uh,
possibly chemistry.
But,
uh,
I learned that there was this new thing
called molecular biology that was just
emerging and that was,
it was very exciting.
So I decided to try it out.
And,
uh,
I ended up majoring in biology a while
taking a lot of chemistry courses.
And,
uh,
I think it was probably a very good
decision because I think the life
science has really have blossomed
tremendously in the past 10,
20,
30 years.
And this is really the golden age now
for biology.
That came a little bit later.
So I had been on the faculty at Mit for
about six,
seven years.
I had tenure and,
uh,
it gave me an opportunity to think about
doing something a little bit risky,
uh,
sort of high risk,
high reward.
And I spent several years thinking what
are some problems out there in biology
now that would fit into that category.
And,
uh,
I thought about a lot of things,
including learning and memory.
And I thought aging was,
was interesting because obviously it's
an extremely important and it wasn't
being studied systematically.
It was being studied from the point of
view of,
uh,
comparing old and young,
and mainly in the medical community.
But in terms of the aging process itself
and moreover,
what might control the aging process?
There wasn't very much,
no,
it was a little bit known,
but not much.
So it looked like a perfect opportunity.
Uh,
but one that,
that had considerable risk.
What made me decide to actually,
uh,
get into it is it turned out so my lab
was at that point,
uh,
studying,
the organism yeast.
And I was a,
a yeast biologists and we had studied
various aspects of cell and molecular
biology in yeast.
And that's really what gained me tenure
at Mit.
And it turned out that yeast cells get
old they age.
So this was a,
for me,
a perfect entry point to the problem.
We could begin by studying how yeast
cells get old.
And that's what we did.
Now we started,
uh,
bashing away at this problem,
in yeast,
uh,
with the idea that we could find genes,
single genes that could confer extra
longevity to yeast cells that are
dividing.
So when you cells divide,
uh,
this is Baker's yeast that I'm talking
about.
The kind of Iste would use to make bread
or wine or spirits.
And it turns out they're very,
very good system to study in the
laboratory,
uh,
to look at cell biology.
Now when these cells divide what you
get,
interestingly of course you get two
salads from one cell,
but they're different.
One is called the mother cell and it's
big and the other is called the daughter
cell.
And it's small.
And it turns out the daughter cell is
all newly synthesized,
all the material and the daughter is
new,
but the mother cell retains the old
stuff.
So that mother cell will then give
another daughter and another daughter
and every generation it will be getting
older and it does that about 20 times
and then it hits the wall and
Senescence.
Okay.
So that,
so it really,
uh,
they're really was aging.
I'll be in,
in a a very baroque system.
So we thought we would be able to make
some headway potentially and identifying
at least what controls this process in
this,
uh,
exotic,
system.
And that's really what intrigued me.
I had,
uh,
at that point,
no,
uh,
plan to study aging more generally then
yeast that came as we got deeper and
deeper into the problem.
Well,
I think the problem,
uh,
yes,
I think the problem with this field and
what has bedeviled this field over the
years is false claims.
And there are all kinds of things that
have been claimed about,
uh,
ways you can slow down or stop aging.
And what I would say they have in common
is that,
you know,
and until,
uh,
anything,
that was claimed,
that's not based on very recent science
is not true.
It's Baloney.
And,
um,
so I wouldn't believe any claim,
uh,
of an anti aging procedure,
and,
uh,
would really look at claims that are
grounded in current science because I
think the science of aging has really
only taken off in the past decade and it
has reached a level of quality that you
can trust it and that it would lead to
interventions that would actually work.
That's only happened recently.
So the,
the thing to look at it,
any claim like this vitamin or that
treatment or that,
uh,
bath,
whatever it may be or cream,
is,
is it based on the recent science of
aging or not?
And if it's not,
I would tend not to believe it.
Even if it is,
I would look at whether it's based on
good science or not.
But there is some good science now in
the area of aging.
No,
no,
I think that,
uh,
what they're saying is,
it's a good example.
I think of something that's not based on
a recent science in the field of aging.
And so,
uh,
you know,
I,
I don't think that there's any reason to
believe that it's true.
I mean,
it may turn out that it is true.
I mean his basic ideas,
we're going to make incremental
discoveries in agent that will make us
live a little bit longer and give us a
little bit more time to make the next
discovery,
which will make us live still longer and
then we'll make more discoveries and so
on and so on and so on and so on.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
that would be great,
but,
uh,
that's certainly not scientific thinking
and that's not based on current science.
So I think that what we're talking
about,
if you look at all the genetic
interventions that have been described
and we should really get into discussing
some of that in a few minutes and all
the dietary interventions that have been
described that promote longevity,
uh,
what you looking at is something like a
50% as a maximum extension?
I would,
I would think so.
It's nothing to sneeze at and,
uh,
it's,
we think,
uh,
accompanied by an increase in the number
of years we stay healthy.
And if we can tap into that and even
develop it so that we get some of the
benefits,
let's say,
10 years of healthier living.
So instead of having to retire and,
uh,
stop,
functioning at a high level,
at age 70 or 75,
you push that back now 10 years.
I think that's a,
a major,
uh,
change in our society aging process.
Uh,
you can describe it statistically in
terms of,
uh,
mortality curves.
And,
uh,
what that means is that the probability
of dying increases,
uh,
with your age.
And the reason is that there's a
degenerative process that's occurring
and cells and tissues that makes,
uh,
you,
increasingly less robust as you get
older and,
uh,
opens up the doors to diseases of aging,
the major diseases,
diabetes,
Alzheimer's disease,
cancer,
cardiovascular disease,
osteoporosis,
and,
uh,
you know,
eventually will kill you.
So,
uh,
it's a very pervasive,
process that has many,
many things going wrong all at the same
time.
Well,
you're,
you're talking to somebody who is,
uh,
not unbiased,
in this area.
And,
um,
you know,
I think the search villains have really
been to my mind,
uh,
but a completely unexpected,
a new thing to come along.
Now,
this came from the studies and yeast
that I described a few minutes ago where
we were looking for aging genes.
And after about nine years of doing
this,
the first nine years we started working
in this area about 19 years ago,
the first nine years were spent in
yeast.
I'm trying to find the right Jean.
And we came upon a gene called cert two
and cert two,
gene was an anti aging gene.
And what I mean by that is when you made
it more active,
the cells live longer,
they divided more times when you made it
less active,
they lived less long.
So this looked like a really interesting
gene and it was the only gene that we
came across that did this.
And so,
so we thought it was interesting.
Then we carried out a similar kind of
study,
uh,
in a different organism that people
study in the lab,
the roundworm see Alec Gans.
And again,
we're looking are there any genes in the
genome c elegans that are anti aging
genes and we've got the same gene.
We got a gene that has the same
sequence,
similar sequence as the cert too.
So that's an amazing finding because
what it means is if the Sir two gene is
counteracting aging in yeast and in
worms that it's doing that universally
and that would include mammals and it
would include us.
So it really right away speaks to a
universality of this process.
So I think that's one thing that's
highly significant about this is that
the gene is conserved and we think its
effect on the aging process is
concerned.
Now,
the piece of this that makes it,
I think particularly exciting as you
say,
well,
okay,
there's this gene,
uh,
that,
makes you live longer.
If it's more active,
why,
why should that be?
What does this gene actually do?
Okay.
And what we know is genes of course,
are the blueprint to specify proteins
and the Sir two genes and code
particular proteins,
the proteins are called Sirtuin.
Okay.
And we're really,
really eager to try and figure out what
the cert actually dead in Sal's.
And just almost exactly 10 years ago,
a little bit more than 10 years ago,
we discovered it and they have an
enzymatic activity in south that enables
them to modify other proteins in cells
and that can really change the
metabolism,
the physiology of a cell,
and then by extension of entire tissues
and an entire organism.
But the critical thing about this
activity is that it was completely
coupled to this small metabolic molecule
in cells called Nad.
So the activity of cert tunes,
which is called deacetylation of other
proteins is absolutely under control of
Nad.
No Nad sort tunes are dead.
Okay.
So the naed links started two wins,
two diet and metabolism because diet and
metabolism affect the availability of
Ned in south.
So we came up with a hypothesis 10 years
ago when we discovered this activity
that Serotonin's might be really be the
link between how diet affects how long
you live and how diet affects your
predisposition to diseases.
And this is a,
it was,
uh,
I think a radical idea.
I think there are a lot of people out
there still critical,
don't believe it.
Um,
but I think the data is mountain in mice
particularly that says that this may
actually be true.
And so the idea would be uh,
that on a low calorie diet,
a diet that's been term calorie
restriction,
we know that rodents live longer and
they resist diseases,
they're disease free under this diet.
And we suggest that the reason for that,
at least one of the reasons,
one of the main reasons is that this low
calorie diet activate Sirtuin,
it's via this molecule nad and that the
more active cert tunes then promote
better survival and better ability to
ward off diseases.
So that's a very simple,
a hypothesis that came from identifying
this activity that I mentioned.
So that's one.
The second thing that came out of that
is once you have an understanding of
what a protein does,
and you can actually measure that in a
test tube.
Now that just has that protein and in
this case Nad at enabled you to screen
for drugs for small molecules that can
enhance that activity.
And it opened the door for looking for
small molecules that could upregulate
the activity of [inaudible].
And that's led to sort of a,
a flood of,
uh,
of interest.
I think probably the part of the story
that's gotten the greatest notice in the
press.
So the first screens that were done
identified a molecule found in red wine
called resveratrol.
That's of a class of compounds that
plants make and response to stress.
They're called polyphenols.
And these compounds could activate,
uh,
the search doing in a test tube and they
also could make cells live longer east
cells and could make worms live longer.
So the remarkable thing,
uh,
seem to be that not only our cert tunes
able to do this,
but we might actually be able to
influence their activity,
uh,
from outside with drugs.
And that really is a,
I think where the,
uh,
excitement began.
And it's still a building because I
think if this is still not completely
appreciate it yet,
so that was,
these are natural products that
resveratrol and uh,
the polyphenols,
the things that are found in wine.
But a company was started by David
Sinclair and Christof Westfall called
Sirtris about,
uh,
six years ago to try and look for new
kinds of molecules now that are not a
natural products.
They're not found in nature by screening
through libraries of different chemical
compounds that have been synthesized.
And there are new kinds of activators
now of cert two wins,
new chemicals that can activate the much
more potently than risk very trial.
And it's going to be extremely exciting
to test these molecules and see what
they'll do.
So far,
what we know is both resveratrol and
some of these newer compounds,
uh,
have beneficial effects in mice and what
they do in minds.
They've been tested against various
diseases.
So what we would expect is if these
molecules are really activating sirtuins
and can protect against diseases of
aging,
then we should be able to demonstrate
that in a mouse.
So it turns out if you feed a mouse,
uh,
basically a bad diet,
the opposite of a calorie restricted
diet.
So a diet high in fat,
high in calories,
the mice get diabetes,
okay?
Now it turns out these molecules
resveratrol and the newer compounds that
activate the cert two wins,
they can protect the mouse against
diabetes.
So the mouse will still eat a lot.
The mouse will still even get fat.
Okay.
But we'll stay metabolically healthy.
So that's a pretty good demonstration
that,
uh,
this idea is not so far out,
but that there really is an opportunity
here to use drugs to keep metabolism
strong and intact as in the face of,
uh,
caloric excess.
Okay.
But even more importantly,
for many of us,
like myself who already,
uh,
I don't calorie restrict,
but I don't eat to access either,
so I'm in good shape,
but even someone like myself would be
able to get benefit from these,
uh,
these molecules by activating sirtuins
in addition to the benefit that I'm
already getting,
my keeping myself in good shape.
So I think it's very,
uh,
it's a very promising area of research.
And this company,
the small company called [inaudible] was
bought by one of the giants in the
pharmaceutical industry.
She asked k for something like three
quarters of $1 billion a year ago.
So obviously that,
uh,
there's at least some validation in big
Pharma that these ideas are realistic
and will be brought to fruition.
I think,
well,
you know,
my lab works on really uncertain ruins
and I think with,
there's so much to be done.
So what we know now is just as the tip
of the iceberg about Sir tones.
So first of all,
there are seven of them in people.
Okay.
And so far,
most of the studies have been focused on
just one of those seven.
Second of all,
there are many tissues that have to be
studied.
So we know what the cert two winds are
doing in each and every tissue so that
we know what the effects of the drug are
going to be,
tissue by tissue.
Uh,
and that's gonna take a long time.
So we're deeply involved in that.
The third thing is,
will these cert two to really protect
against many diseases or will they just
protect against metabolic diseases like
diabetes?
So my lab is really focused focus now on
neurodegenerative diseases and we're
testing the effect of activating,
uh,
the,
the major,
uh,
human cert two in which is called
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
has also been called the survival gene.
Uh,
and we're interested in what if we
activate this and the brain,
will it protect the mouse against
Alzheimer's disease,
against Parkinson's disease,
against Huntington's disease.
And I think these are extremely
important questions because that will
define the sculpt of,
uh,
what we're able to think about here and
what we can start to attack
pharmacologically.
Well,
I mean,
I think a low calorie diet is probably a
good thing.
Um,
I think in humans,
we don't know.
There's no data on what a low calorie
diet does in terms of diseases and,
uh,
longevity,
as I said before,
uh,
by analogy to rodents,
you would think it would be a good
thing.
On the other hand,
uh,
if it made you really miserable to eat a
thousand calories a day,
uh,
and people who are on that diet tend to
be cold.
They tend to,
uh,
have a very low sex drive.
They tend to,
uh,
in some cases be irritable.
And so if you're not happy,
then that gets back to what we were
saying earlier.
You may be undoing some of the good,
uh,
that,
that diet,
uh,
would otherwise produce.
So my feeling is to live sense of way.
I mean the work,
what advice that I think is good.
It's hard to follow,
but I think what everybody should do,
if everybody could do this,
uh,
it's,
it's the best you can do right now is
decide what is your perfect weight,
your body weight,
what's perfect for you.
And I think what most people do is rifle
through the past and,
and,
and the side,
you know,
when they were most happy with
themselves and do everything possible to
get to that weight and keep to it.
And I think that that would,
uh,
necessarily,
make you healthier,
most people healthier than they are now.
Uh,
beyond that,
I,
you know,
I take a vitamin supplement,
a general supplement,
uh,
I take vitamin D,
um,
I do not take resveratrol.
They'll,
a lot of people do.
Um,
and the reason is I'm waiting for a 100%
pure and reliable source of it and then
I will take it.
Um,
and uh,
I drink a little wine and uh,
all the data says,
again,
there's an optimum,
I think the data says that too much wine
is bad,
but no wine is not optima.
The right amount of wine,
uh,
is optimum theirs up center in Louisiana
called the Pennington Center that has
been,
uh,
doing such studies.
It's been a long time since there's been
good data on humans on a calorie
restriction.
And part of the problem has been that,
uh,
humans tend to cheat on the Diet.
So a controlled studies end up not being
so controlled.
Uh,
but recently there have been six months
studies done and what you can do in six
months,
you can't ask if it's making people live
longer.
You can't even ask if it's protecting
them against diseases,
but you can't ask if it's eliciting the
kinds of physiological changes that you
expect in calorie restriction,
which would be a loss of body fat,
a lowering of blood glucose.
It's an antidiabetic,
uh,
effect,
a rendering of a sensitivity to insulin,
the action of insulin.
These can all be measured and six months
in calorie restriction and humans,
that's roughly the same thing that it
does in mice.
Now,
just one footnote on one of those
studies.
So in rodents,
uh,
what we knew is that,
some of these sirtuin activators could
activate a muscle to process glucose
better.
And it was doing that,
at least in part by activating,
uh,
the synthesis of these are organelles
and cells.
They're called the powerhouses of south
that make energy for sounds.
And by activating Mitochondria,
uh,
you sort of drive metabolism and you
drive the uptake of glucose from the
blood into the muscle and the processing
of glucose.
So it's a good thing.
It's an antidiabetic thing.
And this process is,
uh,
can be driven by certain one survival
gene in muscle,
in rodents.
Now,
it was done first with resveratrol,
but it turns out calorie restriction in
rodents does the same thing.
You activate the synthesis of
Mitochondria in muscle.
Okay.
And that makes them more metabolically
active and it's a good thing
metabolically.
Okay.
Not to get back to the humans.
What they were able to show,
uh,
and this trial is they took a punch
biopsies of muscle from the people that
were on the calorie restriction diet for
six months.
And what they found in their muscles was
an increase in Mitochondria and an
increase in the levels of the SAR t one
protein.
The protein was actually increased,
uh,
and the muscle in response to calorie
restriction.
So that says that the congruence
between,
uh,
mice and humans,
maybe a,
a quite profound with regard to calorie
restriction.
So we can't say any,
there's no direct evidence in humans
about diseases,
certainly not about lifespan,
but at least basic physiology.
Uh,
uh,
looks like it might be similar in
humans.
So that might not make a good prediction
about the effects of calorie
restriction,
but nobody wants to practice calorie
restriction because it's,
it's so unpleasant.
And so what everybody would like as a
mimetic,
a drug that would elicit at least some
of the benefits of calorie restriction.
Well,
I would say,
uh,
smoking would be one,
eating to caloric excess.
Okay.
Would be another.
MMM.
Being Sedentary.
Okay.
Uh,
not moving around,
not exercising would be a third.
We didn't talk about exercise,
but there's ample evidence that exercise
is beneficial.
Um,
I think the other thing is what we were
just talking about,
your attitude and mindset.
I think,
you know,
uh,
being focused on negativity would be a
fourth.
And I think the last one,
uh,
which again is,
would,
would be,
uh,
more or less than this lifestyle area
would be stress level,
that level of stress that you maintain
on a day to day basis.
So I believe in it.
Others,
uh,
believe in something called hormesis.
And what horn me this means is that a
lot of stress is a bad thing,
but no,
stress is also a bad thing.
And the optimum is something in the
middle so that you're engaged on a daily
basis.
You're revved up your functioning.
Okay.
But you feel as though you're in
control.
And I think finding that balance,
that horn he says,
uh,
is,
is probably very important in
maintaining mental health and physical
health.
So that would be my,
my big five.
Well,
I would say,
uh,
smoking would be one.
Okay.
Uh,
eating to caloric excess.
Okay.
Would be another,
mmm.
Being Sedentary.
Okay.
Uh,
not moving around,
not exercising would be a third.
We didn't talk about exercise,
but there's ample evidence that exercise
is beneficial.
MMM.
I think the other thing is what we were
just talking about,
your attitude and mindset.
I think,
you know,
uh,
being focused on negativity would be a
fourth.
And I think the last one,
uh,
which again is,
would,
would be,
uh,
more or less than this lifestyle area
would be stress level,
that level of stress that you maintain
on a day to day basis.
So I believe in it.
Others,
uh,
believe in something called hormesis and
what harm me,
so this means is that a lot of stress is
a bad thing,
but no,
stress is also a bad thing.
And the optimum is something in the
middle so that you're engaged on a daily
basis.
You're revved up your functioning,
okay.
But you feel as though you're in
control.
And I think finding that balance,
that warm he says,
uh,
is,
is probably very important in
maintaining,
uh,
mental health and physical health.
So that would be my,
my big five.
I think that at least for the aging
field,
uh,
one,
disappointment I would say that I've had
is that aging is fundamental to so many
diseases.
Yet I really think it's,
it's underfunded in terms of,
uh,
an approach to treating these diseases.
And,
uh,
to give you an example,
I think the past 10 to 20 years has been
an amazing time in the field of aging,
but the fraction of the NIH budget that
goes to research on aging hasn't changed
over that period.
And,
um,
to me that's disappointing because I
think that,
that this is a,
a one,
a leverage point to really improve human
health.
I'm not sure anything is overfunded,
to be perfectly honest.
Uh,
you know,
I,
I think,
uh,
leads most major areas,
of research,
uh,
that I know of are meritorious.
And,
uh,
you know,
if you review grants,
uh,
usually,
the number of grants you see that are
worthy of funding far exceeds the number
that actually get funded.
So,
you know,
I,
I'm not saying I realize it's a
ultimately a zero sum game,
but,
um,
I do think that aging in particular
probably,
uh,
is a little bit underfunded now.
I think the US has always been,
uh,
the best country in terms of encouraging
innovation.
And I think,
you know,
the,
the rise of the NIH and the granting
system,
uh,
after a world war two to now,
as is a really good example of that.
And I know when I was a young scientist,
uh,
you know,
people would apply for grants and they
weren't so hard to get the fraction
funded maybe was 25%,
something like that.
And so that you could propose things
that were a little bit,
uh,
out of the box and have a chance of
getting funded to do it,
which encourages innovation.
I think.
Now once things become,
uh,
so tight and instead of 25%,
you have 10% of grants funded,
then I think,
you know,
any,
any grant that seems the least bit risky
is not going to be funded.
And I think,
uh,
you tend to encourage,
sort of precise,
uh,
calculated,
science,
uh,
at the expense of creative science.
So historically this country has been
the best.
I think I'm a little concerned now that
that might be a trailing off,
although I can't,
uh,
offhand tell you that it's better.
Any other place.
I think one hero I would mention,
uh,
has Galileo and the re and recent for
that.
And the reason I think least to my mind,
uh,
he's the greatest scientist is it,
the way we do science now is to actually
have ideas that we can test with
experiments.
And it's this,
it's called the scientific methods.
So critical to making more than
philosophy.
And I think in earlier civilizations,
the Greeks,
the Romans,
the greatest minds,
the philosophers,
uh,
they just sort of intuited things,
you know,
here's the way things must be.
Uh,
and of course,
that's a recipe for making a lot of
mistakes and for having a,
a false impression of the world.
And we go away,
oh dead was to say,
okay,
I have an idea.
But I think the way to go is to do
experiments and uh,
to test the ideas.
And that I think is,
is the bedrock upon which a modern
science has built.
Also.
I mean,
uh,
he,
he took a lot of heat for what he did in
his lifetime,
uh,
from the Catholic Church and uh,
and he was operating under a pretty
extreme circumstances.
And given those circumstances,
I think he performed pretty darn well.
I think one dilemma you always have is,
um,
our profession really depends on our
being able to publish our work in peer
review journals.
So what gets published,
it's really been,
uh,
gone over with a fine tooth comb.
And so we review each other's papers and
you have to decide when you have a
conflict of interest or not.
And if someone's work is too close to
yours,
if they're a competitor,
I think you have to stay away from it
because there's an obvious conflict of
interest,
a little bit less obvious.
Uh,
if you have people,
uh,
who's,
the people whose papers,
uh,
who wrote the papers are from your lab,
they're former postdocs or students.
I think that's also a conflict of
interest.
And I think it's an,
uh,
it's,
there are gray areas work that's sort of
close to your work.
But I mean,
where,
where do you draw the line of when it's
okay to review someone else's work?
You had a paper or a grant,
uh,
and when is it not?
And when it's self interest,
uh,
creeping in and,
um,
you know,
I think it's very important that the
peer review process,
uh,
is this the best thing we have?
Uh,
that it be as pure as possible.
It's never going to be perfect,
but I think it's worth thinking about.
And,
uh,
and it poses,
it poses dilemmas on a regular basis.